hey what's up everybody welcome to the
are you garbage comedy podcast please
take a second to subscribe to the
YouTube channel that way you get the
episodes as they come out thanks a lot
welcome to another exciting edition of
ru garbage the show where you find out
if your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage I am your host H Foley
coming at you from beautiful Astoria
Queens right here in the epicenter of it
all baby
my co-host coming at you from an
undisclosed location somewhere in
southern New Jersey is our old pal Kippy
Kevin James Ryan everybody hey what's up
gang happy to be here thanks for tuning
in as always quick reminder please rate
review subscribe on iTunes you too thank
you for everybody leaving reviews and
comments and subscribing we appreciate
it
I keep doing that and tell a friend tell
a pal to check out the show as well let
him know gang come on with us and our
very special guest today we go way back
to where Moses wore short pants she's an
absolute get we are so happy to have her
here jfl comedy festival in Montreal
Canada documentary series on amazon
prime and most recent bill burns the
ringers on Comedy Central she's an
excellent stand-up comedian performed
all over the country our good pal Rosie
shaker Baker rosebud Baker everybody I
was late I'm sorry I [ __ ] adopted a
puppy yesterday it happened I just so I
sat down to look at Mike to like open up
my computer I was looking my phone I saw
you just posted a picture of the puppy
like 25 minutes ago and I'm like oh
there was no way I literally my head I'm
like dude she just got a puppet there's
no way she's on top I saw the puppy I
want to eat it I was honestly we might
have to
who you are we're out in Los Angeles
there's we haven't you can't [ __ ] get
groceries here I don't know how it is
there but you can't get groceries here
without waiting in a line for like that
wraps around a building so this dogs
gonna be lucky if she makes it a week
looking pretty delicious she's so cute
what's your name her we named her mouse
okay that's respectable you can tell a
lot of garbage about people depending on
what they name their dog yeah I know
names I know real garbage what do you
thinks the biggest garbage pet name I
mean the obvious is fluffy fluffy
I had a fluffy that got hit by a car
when I was real little if your dog's
name was fluffy your your mom never you
never saw your mom come home from work
yeah for sure
first you know what I'm saying if I
think fluffy or like spot it's pretty
[ __ ] spot if your dog's name is spot
you probably were on like you part of
the Yacht Club or some [ __ ] you know
which is a different kind of garbage
spots like it's bustling it's like
ironically normal like crazy rich people
have like oh come here spot cuz they
want to feel they want to feel like a
normal person a little bit name the dog
Remington or something like that but
fluffy fluffy fluffy never made it out
of the fire
fluffy was always a casualty of that we
tried to go back in for fluffy but
couldn't find him anyway Rosie it's
great to have you here buddy as you said
you're out there on the coast or in the
middle of the the cove it 19 quarantine
other than that how are things out there
you holding up I mean it was it sucks I
was out I came out here for pilot season
I was in the middle of shooting
something it was like a stand up series
for Netflix I was [ __ ] psyched about
it and you know we get a week into
filming and I was like they were like
yeah pack it up go home I was like all
right great fantastic Jesus sucks and
now they're like you know
some stuff on your phone as like a video
diary and I'm like what what are we
doing here some of that stuff can
[ __ ] take a hike I've seen some of
them big yes Annelle they did an SNL
last night with from home I don't know
if anybody everybody saw it I didn't see
I haven't seen it yet but I'm definitely
gonna watch it I can't foresee it being
that great I saw some of the late nights
it's all like Conan we're like I love
Cohn and I grew up on Conan he'd respect
it you know I like to see just like
these people trying on their cell phones
I'm like dude what are we just running
they were rerun and pay your staff what
do we do what are we yeah exactly I mean
I don't understand it's like why I mean
the whole reason they're doing it is
just so they don't have to pay a bunch
of people their [ __ ] royalties you
know yeah it's it sucks but you know I
think our industry is dead and I'm gonna
learn how to cook I just hope to god
that my eggs aren't dead because the
only option it seems like I adopted a
dog already I got engaged there's
nothing else to do except to have a kid
so you know I'm just gonna make it
happen
goes back into the 70s I think
songwriting will become really big I
think rock music is gonna come back in
the next couple of years that's what I
predict musics gonna come back there's
gonna be a new Bruce Springsteen I'll
tell you this when we're finally out of
here
I think me two rules are gonna go out
the [ __ ] window it's gonna be
assaulted yes no one's gonna be asking
for tackling my friends yeah that's easy
how do you think that's all gonna gonna
plan cuz people are saying that like
everything's gonna be changed forever
that's the first thing I want to do is
hug and kiss people when I get the [ __ ]
out of here yeah I mean if it doesn't if
the whole city isn't burning and being
looted then yeah that will be like my
first priority but I think it's gonna be
like finding New York and all the people
that like move there thinking like Oh
New York it's gonna it's such a tough
city
like they're gonna get the city that
they heard about when they moved there
you say me [ __ ] turn yeah it's gonna be
summer of Sam is what I'm saying that's
all I'm gonna be nuts I mean you think
it's awesome it's it's gonna be awful
it's gonna be awful I know that thinks
you know like in Brooklyn who's like you
know yeah tough in and out in New York
City they're done they're leaving
they're gonna be gone because if their
guy they're gonna be gone or they're
gonna be stabbed and I think that is
what is gonna happen like wow I do think
I think comedy is gonna change like
forever I think people are gonna want
jokes again I think people are gonna I
mean I don't know for sure or I think
stand-up could just be done and it could
be like podcasting and it's grim
predictions by Rosen rosebud open a
window do something a little bit you
guys turn it in you're finished
Rosie's just trying to get us all to
quit so she comes back I'm still holding
out I'm still holding out yeah I mean
nobody's actually I think the people
that are funny are gonna stick around
because they have nowhere else to go
sure I also think like what are like the
you know the open mic errs do you know
like the people who have like they just
moved to New York and they're like oh
I'm gonna get into it it's like you were
bad to begin with and now you're gonna
take out you're gonna take six months
off or whatever it's like it's gonna
really thin the herd yeah absence also
which is like then yeah like yeah and
yeah finally podcasting is definitely
definitely something that's gonna be
hopefully pulling some income Kippy
well also now this Foley Foley found out
weekend podcast from our homes he's
never gonna leave that haha I've been
loving the fact that I can do [ __ ] just
from my house it's great yeah if there
was the option to go outside that would
be great but um since that's not an
option I'm good with this this is fine
yeah Foley oh you mean your new podcast
be my 600-pound podcast they're gonna
have to take you out of the house
through the wall like you know for like
a couch that's too big but I'll be
broadcast in the entire time so that's
[ __ ] that that's premium content
right yeah that's that'll be behind the
paywall for sure I've been feeling like
that person just like because every time
I eat I'm like there's I know that I'm
only fueling up to eat another meal
that's the only thing I'm doing I know
I'm gonna have another full meal within
the next 45 minutes always in the heaven
yeah seven I'm singing in the kitchen
dancing around no I promise are you good
are you and your lady quarantined
together
yeah we're quarantined together it's
actually working out we're having a good
time we're shopping or [ __ ] cooking
it's going good mail me a gun please
where's that 3d printer and and one
bullet yeah crazy I I mean we we seem to
be doing pretty well me and and you're
doing okay like it's not congratulations
by the way
congratulation game lutely thanks man
great guy that Andy Haines tight little
body on him - not gonna lie kids enjoy
robot he's got swimmers body that guy
yes he does I mean
he's just doing right now just things
are going great see listen watching a
show on his phone with his headphones on
no he's sleeping or trying to sleep but
I'm screaming in the living room and
it's fine it's like we we got engaged
second day of quarantine thinking you
know be done in a week or something we
got divorced the fourth day currently
seeing other people online no I think we
dyed his hair orange which is a great
because I feel like I'm [ __ ] somebody
else and I don't know I feel like we're
gonna be we're gonna be fine I'm not
right I'm not really worried about it
honestly that seems to be the quarantine
move is the divert here I wanted to
shave my head because I don't have
anything I mean it's gonna be a couple
like you know you're saying it's gonna
be [ __ ] 12 years but the way I look
at it it's gonna be a couple more months
where I have to audition for anything so
why not shave the head but Kippy Kippy
was like not not a good luck I mean he's
the only thing you have going for you is
your head of hair that's legit the only
thing you have you do I'm talking full
head of hair you're gonna take that off
you're gonna look like a thumb yeah chai
in our on diet if anything just diet
like maybe Frost the chips yeah Oh some
tips it's what I'm talking about
I want to get it was like Joey Fatone
left in a river like they fished him out
of the Hudson I said I'm getting I'm
doing tips I'm dumb going to see
yesterday getting tips get fresh tips
it's gonna be the new craze and
post-apocalyptic New York might as well
I mean what the [ __ ] who cares
what about a show about a podcaster
vigilante we can pitch that in New York
after this is all over like $9 you guys
remember night collar no because we're
not eighty he was the real it was a real
sis
our [ __ ] it's it's insane sometimes
currents there's a real garbage 80s TV
show that me and my mom used to love the
lots together she'd sit there and
chain-smoked marble lights and we'd
watch night caller he was that everybody
has everybody has a show that they would
watch with their mom while their mom got
drunk you know yeah yeah that was
anything on TV for me yeah Saturday
morning cartoons that was my recital
never forget that talent show thanks for
coming mash was a big one for us that
was me my mom she that's insane that you
watched Matt like I don't even to me
that's literally from the 1920s in my
head it was never on when like I was
growing uh you know that was something
that was well I watched the season
finale
I watched the series finale of mash the
highest-rated television program and in
the of all time with my mom it's a great
show I'm too bad she can't remember any
[Laughter]
good ER with my mom and I remember yeah
I didn't know I didn't know that she was
hammered the whole time every every
[ __ ] week she would ask me she'd be
like so what happened last week like
she's like acid asked me to fill her in
and finally I learned what getting drunk
was and I was like this [ __ ] what is
that George Clooney doing I don't
understand
wait so they're all doctors there's no
idea what that was a show that my dad
would walk by and watch me and my mom
watch me be like kind of [ __ ] see me get
anything done at this hospital real
[ __ ] in bed together he'd understand
it at all all right let's get into some
get into the game here we have our very
special guest as everybody knows our
good pal rosebud Baker also known on the
streets to the West Village as ribs
Baker yeah our good pal
we're gonna get into some questions here
we know she's an accomplished stand-up
comedian she's doing very well but we
have to find out hey she garbage Kippy
what do you think I don't know I mean I
don't think so I know she comes from a
pretty good family she's got some good
stock in her you know what I mean you
know she's a little edges she's got a
bit of an attitude problem from time to
time
I think she's no she's not garbage I
definitely think she you know she's
definitely put a toe in the you know the
the garbage pool at times I feel maybe a
garbage phase but yes I say with that it
down a hundred percent no she's not
garbage like you're garbage that's not
the case there's levels yes yeah yeah
well I think we have some interesting
questions here we're gonna find out
Rosie thank you so much again for being
here
Kippy do you want to kick it off yeah do
you want to you want to do the basics
with with Rosie where did you yeah okay
where are you where did you grow up by
the way I don't even know I grew up
outside of DC in Alexandria Virginia
what yeah that's where the show loans
are from I know yeah I thought you were
a kid all the way no really she was East
Coast yeah Wow the plot thickens you
don't you don't get somebody this is
angry from the wagon that's like years
generational alcoholism is you rosebud
you put that in a [ __ ] combustion
chamber yeah yeah I what grocery store
did you go to growing up Safeway
so he plays a little bi see that ain't
good I never never seen a nice Safeway
paint me a picture here in Alexandria
that's did you
in the burbs right I grew up in the
burbs
so Alexandria is like it's kind of
developed now but it's it's like a
suburb of DC you know it's where a lot
of [ __ ] I don't even know what
they're called senators they're like
kids and their wives I can raise them up
in Alexandria or in McClane which is
where we move to later on and it's like
a it's just like an old townie looking
place but it's really well populated
okay so it has like the same almost like
look of DC all right but it's but it's
not it's it's just it's just a [ __ ]
town you know what I mean actly yeah we
had a driveway yeah gravel or paint
paved okay who has gravel [ __ ]
driveways people I know well here's the
thing it was paved but it was like paved
gravel like you miss gravely still it
wasn't like a smooth paved road snow
plow come up you could but it was you
couldn't you could roller skate on it
but it'd be a rocky Rock strap in you're
in for a bumpy ride that's garbage
roller skate in the driveway
yeah that's great there we go now we're
peeling the onion back a little bit okay
did you have a cleaning lady growing up
big thing in the 80s and 90s a cleaning
lady did she raised me yes do I speak
Spanish she was my mom okay was it did
you wish you there daily or was it like
weekly or what was the schedule on the
cleaning daily did she live there
she later on she lived there after my
mom had more kids
she lives that's a little bit of scratch
right there like that I
early I literally called her mommy Nana
so like I had mom and mommy Nana and
then so mommy Nana
spoke she's from Bolivia and she was
from [ __ ] I don't think she was from
North Carolina
no she wasn't Venezuelan is what I'm
saying
and she she spoke Spanish to us and we
didn't bother to learn it back so yeah
yeah yeah keep it moving lady making
eggs are cooked all right I'm like all
right you're my second mom so we had a
cleaning lady growing up but she would
only cut she would come on she would
only come once a week and we had to like
clean for her to clean I was like this
is this doesn't matter I was like the
cleaning lady's coming clean your room
I'm like what the hell we paint is
brought a clean my room if the cleaning
lady's coming [ __ ] stupid how about she
cleans then I'll vacuum how about that
my gonna cuddle
yeah yes [ __ ] [ __ ] she still
comes actually this is a kind of a
garbage thing I was home not too long
ago for something and me and my couple
of friends that still live at home went
out to like you know did the town pub
and got all [ __ ] banged up I'm like
sleeping on the couch nobody was
supposed to be home I knew my mom nobody
was home so I was there I'm sleeping in
my underwear like hung like drunk like
hung out on my booze and she comes in to
clean apparently her assistant and I'm
like my balls are hanging out on my
cloth on the couch and she's like Kevin
I'm like oh I'm like I wrap myself up
stated talk about like I'm in my 30s
cleaning lady walking is your [ __ ]
ball bag I know I'm not Santa what do
you want me to bend her too much I know
I know Justin we only promised the
American Dream and she got your [ __ ]
ballsack no she's actually she's like
she's like my mom's friend she's just
like a regular white chick it's crazy
oh yeah well I didn't listen to that
part of the story I don't think I said
that
soon she was South America no it's a
good shot in the dark I mean it's an
educated guess
we only got a cleaning lady only like
like once every couple years of
something real special what's happened
and we felt like a couple years
something your family Kennedys what had
happened we all lined up out front like
the sound the music we thought it was
Mary Poppins
all right Safeway cleaning lady let's
get into some family eating habits
that's what I'd like to know what was I
yeah
were you a mayonnaise family no no
mayonnaise we didn't know nobody that's
see that right there is why I think
she's not garbage because I think a lot
of things that I do discuss rosebud and
that's a good indicator a lot of things
you do discuss those people but let's
put an Astra you do you eat a lot of
mayonnaise it's coming out of his pores
but I don't not eat a lot of mayonnaise
I eat mayonnaise a wedding it we have
mayonnaise in the house when I was a kid
I [ __ ] hate mayonnaise it's
disgusting I don't like the smell of it
makes me want to puke yes no that
actually makes me want to apply for
welfare okay what about I'm what about
lunches when you were a kid what was
that what was the lunch situation would
you be buying a lunch at school would
you go to school do you go to a private
school or a public school I went to
public school okay my sister's all went
to private school and I went to public
school why I think because my parents
were like as she can handle it that's
the black sheep of the squadron right
there yeah yeah it's not like we're not
we're not gonna bother spending extra
money on this one but I actually like
needed I like needed it I was in like
the small classrooms you know what I
mean as I was like I needed extra time
on tests and [ __ ] I was like [ __ ] so
they so I don't know why
but I was kind of I think that's why I'm
like different from my sisters cuz my
sisters all have like good jobs and
stuff and I you know do this I comedian
yes anyway I tell you were killing me
before all that time that we put into
this [ __ ] seven years up here I was
getting rid of all of the Tribeca Film
Festival in a couple of weeks I was
[ __ ] even the way here
he was catering outlets til I was
parking cars but still 11 years of work
down the [ __ ] tubes in two seconds
I'm like I think we're all [ __ ] but
anyway that's about all you'll be having
for a while yeah I know it's I'm just
enjoying it while it lasts but I I went
to pop I went to public school and I was
like I bought lunches but but it wasn't
it wasn't a bad public school you know
what I mean it was like it was one of
the we had one of the better public
school systems we got went to a public
school where people got cars for their
16th birthday yeah you know seven semis
similar to me yeah did you ever get
suspended or expelled or anything yeah
for what yeah
sexual harassment what what yeah I tried
to stick a broom up my friends ass and I
got suspended for sexual harassment
that's a good a guy or a girl
the teacher that saw me do it reported
me sexual harassment
Oh get the [ __ ] out you know what I mean
that's grab-ass that's what that is I
was like I'm just sticking a broom up
his ass for a long time yeah I want you
to take the one out of yours
yeah buddy let's go oh I I was like I to
this day I remember going into the
principal's office and being like did
something happen
a broom for this guy that reported me
yeah that's like I remember being like
it's a clearly a joke like what I need
to know what happened to this guy's anus
with a broom yeah if he wants to know
what harassment is I will harass him for
that yeah that's [ __ ] insane that's
[ __ ] were you smoking in this high
school were you smoking under the under
the bleachers and all that yeah another
thing was smoking did your pant before
you were 18 did your parents know and
allow you to smoke those kids were
always a little [ __ ] a little dicey
where you were like 14 okay I was
actually like such an addict from the
very beginning like I started smoking
not even because I like wanted to it's
just like people forgot my birthday and
I was 18 so I started smoking and as
like an act of like [ __ ] everybody yeah
and then for some reason I really
enjoyed the fact that I could hide it
from people so I would smoke in my car
and I wouldn't even tell my boyfriend at
the time so like the way that they found
out that I was smoking was it was
raining one day and I was like ashing
out my window and there was ash on the
side of my car and my mom noticed it and
my boyfriend noticed it and they
everybody noticed it the same on the
same day and I was like goddamn it
but I loved smoking like I loved keeping
it a secret and like getting in my car
and just being it made me feel so adult
to like hide my cigarettes garbage but I
liked it that's really garbage that's
like something out of oil tannin bombs
yeah
my my house I still kind of like I mean
I used to like hide it from my mom still
even in like my 20s you know what I mean
I just I wouldn't like celebrate it I
would always like I don't know it said
Irish yeah like like shameful sneaking a
smoke
but do I had a buddy growing up who his
parents like let him smoke it like 14 or
something they were like well-off I
guess dad was like you know like some
like big financial adviser guy like
they're like a huge house they were like
very well-off and educated they just
like let them smoke it like four
and they do I remember on Christmas in
his stocking he got a carton of Newports
and a thing of condoms I'm like get the
[ __ ] outta God dude and I'm like what
kind I'm like this kid doesn't stand a
chance in life like you're literally
giving them new son and condoms and he's
still at home he was he do now he still
does so this [ __ ] family fast jerking
off and condoms and smoking new pees all
day it's awesome of course Newports -
that's a weird choice we all started on
new senators son yeah we all started on
Newports I don't know why I started on
Newports - yeah why - I don't understand
that everybody smokes Newports when they
first I don't know I they [ __ ] me up -
I got like sick oh yeah that would rock
- [ __ ] audience it's like eating a tuba
toothpaste that [ __ ] gets [ __ ] yeah
it's extremely bad Buffy finds rat
poison they're like another as an older
kid like there's fiberglass in it so it
gets into your lungs quicker I'm like
okay okay I was a child cranking
Newports like a [ __ ] as if my lungs are
gonna have a hard time is that true by
the way did do Newports have fiberglass
in them to shred your lungs up I think
all my dad does that was like I think
menthol cigarettes have happened or
something I don't know also I don't
[ __ ] know but man that's [ __ ] up
yeah all right what about a bellybutton
piercing your bellybutton piercing
growing up that's pretty garbage um I
the only time I ever had a belly button
piercing was because I got in a fight
with my boyfriend and he had made it
known how much he hated bellybutton
piercings and I went out and got my
bellybutton pierced to piss him off
that's its you are an insane person
that's [ __ ] yeah that's like that's
that's [ __ ] crazy
yeah I went home and I was like hey look
what I did do you like it you are
diabolical cold-blooded [ __ ] you need
a shrink or you've seen a therapist
right now remind me to never
double-cross rosebud bakers
awesome you this was before I ever
started seeing one but for sure
definitely pissed him off yeah in high
school we'll use a girl that dated older
did you date older guys in high school
yeah 38 year old dude picking you up
from not battle your like true
intentions yeah I wanted a boyfriend
that was like in college but I I settled
for the ones that were like seniors you
know yeah and then and then once they
went to college I would like still see
them and be like oh I have a boyfriend
in college you know yeah but like cheat
on him yeah it was
I was trash he's a trash teenager yeah
I'm starting to pick up on that yeah did
you ever have that boyfriend beat
somebody up in school no but he would
show up outside oh you're [ __ ]
garbage if your boyfriend if your old
boyfriend is showing up unannounced
places to like find me with someone yeah
now he would do that a lot and then I
mean every reason to do that because I
was cheating Oh like Dawson's Clank I
know what the [ __ ] I remember just being
like you're so [ __ ] crazy but then
like getting in my car and being like
wow how do you see that coming
this guy's pretty good Jesus
oh [ __ ] girlfriend did you ever wear
glitter makeup no I never really wore a
lot of makeup okay there you go that was
always I was always a big some girl [ __ ]
so a party or something and I'm [ __ ]
glitter all over her face I'm like
something body glitter yeah some body
butter is really the thing that tips you
off if they're wearing Victoria's Secret
body glitter yeah yeah there's some
issues for sure when you rock an Ed
Hardy back in the day ed hardy is like
isn't that for like Latino men that was
the waspey [ __ ]
I believe for Latino man your jaw went
out three into dudes yeah no I think
what yeah it hard he wasn't really like
a woman's thing know who you're who
you're interviewing he doesn't know what
ed hardy is he's just heard it he's like
I thought girls were those all all cut
up they would like they would like
sliced t-shirts up and wear them I
thought that was the Ming back in the
day I don't think so I don't think that
was ever a thing unless unless you're
talking about like the bikers
girlfriends I yeah were you a bikers
girlfriend I did I dated a guy that had
a Harley for a little while did you
write them back at that Harley yes I did
element or no helmet helmet topless what
were you wearing
have you ever do you remember never
given anybody the finger while you were
on the back of that motorcycle for
traffic situations because that's real
garbage you ever see videos or that
would like the girl but I was a side
chick while I was riding it so that does
yummy you know yeah you making you make
the bed you sleep in there rosebud
dating a guy on a Harley like well
actually he was seeing other people yeah
yeah yeah these are oh man I'm not proud
of this but it's fun
we is celebrated here it celebrates yeah
I love it
okay yeah I got another have you ever
worn Crocs no okay
no Crocs never owned crops what about
you don't I did on a pair of Uggs I did
where that marks aren't trashy though I
mean they were like that was they were
like the most popular thing that's um I
was in Boston at
time yeah you can see the memories
hitting her should be like yeah and then
like her like eyes lower her shoulders
drop she's like answer are you an
alcoholic
speaking of alcohol you obviously you're
you're sober now but did you back when
you used to boost ever drink wine with
ice in it I didn't know any better wine
or red wine both this is warm I mean I
was I didn't I didn't read the manual
straw over here please thank you worst
part about it is that I wasn't
surrounded by classy enough people to
tell me not to sure yeah I was last
night is that my taste in people led me
to that oh of course you have somebody
who would have known would have been
like yeah a rose but you lay off the ice
on the Merlot you know what yeah last
night I was sitting I was sitting at
home and I poured a wine I'm like maybe
I could drop a piece of ice in it I'm
like now I can't do it I can't do it I
want to do that sure no you are drinking
there Reds a little cooler these days
but ice is [ __ ] garbage hold on hold
on my gonna do a zoom thing well I watch
the peak can you hand her to me sorry I
got a hold the puppy yeah so sorry only
one guest at a time Rose but I'm sorry
the dog Hank the dog can't stay yeah ah
that's a nice little doggie she's so
small oh look at her a little
shit-eating mouth yeah what kind of dog
she's uh Brussels Griffon Chihuahua mix
oh that's cute so we stop talking like
that it's [ __ ] I can't help it
there was 45 year-old mayonnaise I love
it I love it when dogs turn people into
different people it's my favorite thing
isn't that garbage rose buddy you're a
dog person is that garbage you think
when men talk baby talk to doggies they
don't like that I just wouldn't know I'm
so mad it's so embarrassing like I
respect you as it as a person at times I
respect you as a person and then you go
and do that it's like how am I supposed
to like look you in the eye well just
let me explain this to you Kippy this is
exactly what I do first I take one of
those little piggies
my skin is I'll have my blood is running
cold that's cuz you were a latchkey kid
you didn't have a dog when you were
growing I had multiple doors oh you know
what is going up and you don't do baby
talk to dogs I do but not in front of my
other adult male friends in your heart
you need to open your heart put some ice
cubes in some wine that's sexual
harassment again you're gonna get
suspended from the box
don't be double-crossing rosebud after
those stories you wake up with the
[ __ ] vacuum cleaner down your throat
my belly button piercing recording a
Foley go where she goes she go ahead I
gotta run out of time you do you either
do do you call either of your parents or
answer uncles by their first names oh
that's a good one like a Steve all of
them hey wait your parents and your
aunts and uncles my aunts and uncles I
all call them by their first names my
mom and dad youko or
are you called my mom nanny I call my
dad dad okay why do you call your mom
nannies is her name like Nancy or
something yeah her name's Nancy but
everybody calls her nanny that's a
little done yeah well like if you're
really your uncle Steve's house you're
like hey what's up Steve how you doing
yeah
oh that is a lack of respect right there
you don't say uncle Steve no really
that's you I old oh I still do my aunt
Sheila my aunt Kathy my aunt Colleen
yeah my mom um did you do it is that did
you yeah did you do it as a kid or were
you a nine year old going hey Kathy can
I get in can I get some can I get some
wine with I don't remember ever calling
an uncle dog or like aunt Susie you
called them mr. mrs. Baker kept it real
precious mother Susie I just called him
Susie dog GD grant we're changing this
episode two are you a psychopath child
did you ever kill anybody at your prom
that's between me and a limo driver
that's crazy
have you ever murdered a landscaper
that's too funny were you allowed to
curse in front of your parents as a kid
like you could you be at the dinner
table like what the [ __ ]
uh yeah that's all we're gonna allow -
but I did all the time I'm not you were
not a fun gal to be around as I don't
this is not trash though this is like
because I was definitely not supposed to
do it but this just came from like a
pure pure love of curse words like from
the time that I learned them I was like
this I just got the keys to the [ __ ]
kingdom the first time I heard the word
[ __ ] I was like what did you just
[ __ ] say to me I was like I remember
I practiced it on the soccer field
because I saw our game and I remember
going into that soccer
and being like I'm gonna curse all over
this goddamn field I've done that too
like I'm like yeah wait till they hear
what I gotta say
Rose my Baker rosebud Baker ended the
game with three points five assists and
twelve [ __ ] 19 f-bombs the B
word the S word she call her mom did not
score once nothing no defense no offense
I scored on everybody out
I scored on my own goal but I did call
that guy [ __ ] so it all even at
the end of the day you've got a
cigarette in your mouth running around
the field way to be an adult we got a
couple more here I got one that's gonna
lock it in I'm guaranteeing a yes on
this
it's the two-part question have you ever
been to the sandals resort
say it no all right have you ever gone
to a Caribbean island and come back with
cornrows in your hair with your hair
braided no once you've definitely been
sitting on like a Delta flight wear with
a braid listen I swear on the dead guy
in my prom I promise you I never came
back with cornrows I never once yeah
that is a rate that I was able to
somehow skip have you ever owned a jet
ski no hmm did I ask my parents for one
yes and you didn't get it I didn't get
it you know what's kind of really fine
now my we had one but I wasn't allowed
to use it which was like I was like oh
come on let me enjoy on the phone that
sucks I don't know I just wasn't allowed
to use because they were probably
writing it out on the weekends my
stepdad had one and I wasn't allowed to
use it did anybody growing up did you
have a hot tub that wasn't like building
to the ground like a like you know what
it like like I like an aftermarket hot
tub that you like that they give away on
The Price is Right for like 35 no we
never had that you have a pool in the
backyard no oh yes we did have a pool
okay yeah later
those after we moved to McClain so that
was when we were like higher class my
dad got promoted
he got more money was your hot tub
connected to that pool no was there a
diving board or a sliding board there
was a diving board
okay its average run-of-the-mill no slow
slide if you had a slide George know you
were doing all right if you had a fine
line you were doing a round pool with a
slide lookout [ __ ] class right there
yeah you got a six flags in your
backyard
yes yeah my buddy got one when we were
kids and we were like I had a pool with
a diving board and then my buddy got a
big pool hot tub diving board sliding
board I looked at my dad I'm like you
better step your [ __ ] game like you
piece of [ __ ] if you think I'm in this
[ __ ] ass pool you gotta come back
Jostens got a [ __ ] slide and the big
diving board with the spring you know
yeah yeah see this is why you can't have
kids cuz they're gonna they're gonna
come home they're gonna look at their
friends [ __ ] pool they're gonna come
on be like [ __ ] is this piece of [ __ ]
house that you just put together for me
yeah keep you alive yeah one of the
biggest piece of [ __ ] things I ever did
and I always I always think about it too
is exactly what you're talking about my
dad bought us a car all right for for
high school I was gonna be it was it was
my sophomore year my brother senior year
so my brother was gonna drive it for his
senior year and then I would have a car
for my junior and senior year and be
driven to school every day in my 10th
grade year because of my brother and it
was a Chevy spectrum but I didn't know
what the [ __ ] a Chevy spectrum was but I
never saw a picture of it and when he
pulled into the driveway with that it
was like this little black like 80s
hatchback which I
and grew to absolutely love but the
first time I saw it he gets out of the
car I go that's it I want to punch you
right now for doing oh [ __ ] my dad out
there busting his ass [ __ ] drew - 300
miles a week
[ __ ] pulls up in this karmic that's
it come on yeah and I'm ever normally
he'd be like tough with me with this
situation like that like go for you what
are you talking about
he literally was like I'm sorry oh yeah
you broke you broke his spirit all right
relax jetski boy you break your dad's
spirit that's the worst feeling yeah
yeah God
I've done it many times my dad had five
daughters so his spirit was out of the
80s that guy he's done I mean you see
him now and he looks like a cheeseburger
shell of a man just a shell of a man
yeah he married my stepmom he married my
stepmom because he he just fell down the
stairs alone in his apartment one day he
was like I asked somebody to marry me my
daughters aren't gonna help you know
it's pretty trashy I said this the other
day because I have an ex stepmom I'm
like that is that as a level yeah that's
like does she still say he's presents
for Christmas and stuff like that no but
we do text occasion because I have two
brothers I have two half brought she has
you know two kids or two half-brothers
she had kids with my father so we still
were in contact and stuff but I said it
the other day I was explaining to
somebody I'm like oh yeah like my ex
stepmom and I was like oh that one hits
a little different and x-step mom my
stepmom and I don't even [ __ ] talk I
don't even talk to her and Mary Larry
yeah she sucks do you call her she hears
that you call her momma Dee call her
Meredith I call her Meredith I know I
was joking yeah be so funny if I called
her it'd be so [ __ ] if I called her
mom
if I walked in one day and do it you
should do that if you want to be like me
because you are a [ __ ]
hi you barren [ __ ] really lady Rosie we
get answer we gotta get a treatment
going on all this this is good stuff
here get Ryan C Bay on the phone
absolutely no problem he's next door I
think I just got one more here I guess I
got two growing up which I don't think
so did your parents have a station wagon
growing up yeah oh that stuff was there
wood paneling on that station wagon yes
it's official rose but here's the thing
halfway through my life my dad started
making money so and my sisters weren't
born until then so like I have this
totally different kind of childhood than
they have like station wagon I see a
shitty driveway like like throw me out
in the yard in a diaper kind of what a
railroad kid kind of yeah a station
wagons a station wagons a tough look cuz
you you gotta figure what the you like
what the thought process is to buy in a
station wagon back in the day I mean I
guess I mean they were very popular
utility vehicles I know they really were
I would I would rock one now for sure
you know you throw a couple of buddies
in the back I was telling Foley my my
buddies we never had one but my my
growing up my friend had one and his in
the back of it they had they was sold
they had the seats that faced out back
like do you remember that out back the
win yes we had oh no we didn't have
those my friend had those they were fun
yeah I remember see I was like a six
year old being like this is [ __ ]
sketchy I'm like this could just [ __ ]
crush me right now it's a whole
different world in the back we're sure
given people the finger like well Rosie
buddy we want to thank you so much for
sitting here with us and playing
you garbage the puppies adorable
congratulations on the on the engagement
I'm gonna give her a number here I'm
gonna say she's stationwagon kinda
weight station wagon weight one is this
one - what one out of a hundred so it's
percent garbage so you're like you're
like a 22% garbage I'll give you that's
not bad that's not bad that's not bad
I'm scared to give a number because the
kind of garbage that rosebud is is the
kind of garbage that would ruin the
lives of garbage like my family sure she
would have our shoes she would like have
my dad rubbed out or something like that
or she's she pull some strings and have
them like relocated to Alaska to work
hey congrats a congratulations on your
dad's promotion you like what and then
your dad calls you right away so yeah
I'm not saying but that was so much fun
there's anything you want anybody to
know out there Rosie I know the dates
are slowed down a little bit because of
the corona but they can go subscribe to
my podcast comedy it's called devil's
advocate with rosebud Baker and we
talked about well I've been doing a lot
of solo cast lately but usually I have a
guest on we talked about the worst thing
that ever happened to them and why that
makes them so funny and and lately I've
just been basically talking [ __ ] myself
in a room yeah she's been really fun but
yeah you can subscribe to that you can
also subscribe to my other podcast find
your Beach that me and my fiancee
Beyonce Andy Haynes have that we started
on the first day of quarantine and we've
been doing it every single day of the
quarantine very nice so yeah if you want
to watch a relationship fall apart you
can you want to see a marriage end
before it starts tune in to Roosevelts
Bob
very nice Rosie thank you so much Kippy
what do you got for the gang out there
that's all I got as you are but please
rate review subscribe on iTunes Spotify
YouTube share with a friend and people
are hitting us up with questions and
stuff like that I forgot to I had a
couple after got to read them but you
can DM them to us or email or you know
whatever to get them to us somehow if
you follow us very nice great stuff guys
Rosie thank you so much
my puppy doggy mm-hmm thank you guys
they are now safe my mouse head loves
you give me smooth day bye Mike let me
go okay bye bye oh dear
you